these people all got rich in the
influencer revolution and in this video
I'm going to break down exactly how they
did it how I built my personal brand and
how you can too and yes that's
you my close friend Taylor Swift has
built one of the top 20 net worths of
self-made women and has one of the
single strongest personal Brands as a
woman in existence today and here are
five things that I learned from what
she's done in building her brand that I
use for me the first thing that I
learned from her longevity do you know
how old she was when she made her first
song 16 it was in 2006 Tim McGraw was
the first song that she released these
people have actually a very long time
under their belts of how many years they
put in to their personal brand 14 years
ago news Force Harry buer met an
aspiring country music singer from
Hendersonville high school and so a lot
of times we're measuring a two-year
career against a 20-year career and
everything compounds with time she
gained more popularity in the last 12
months than she probably did in the
first 19 years which sounds crazy but at
the same time is also true and so that's
what Taylor did for longevity but what
did I do my first podcast was in July of
2017 six plus years that I've been
making content now to be fair hers was
at a larger scale and as I actually
increased my scale so too did my
branding awareness and reach follow you
got to do the same thing in a lot of
quantity for a very long time before it
really starts to get going don't compare
your first year to someone's 10th year
the longer you do something the better
you get at it also the longer you do
something the more you have done because
if I post once a week for a year versus
once a week for 10 years it's talking
about 520 videos versus 52 videos so I'm
going to have all of the compounding of
all those other videos that going to be
bringing people to my world that whole
time plus 520 reps of being good at that
thing and just to give you some numbers
around this my first year of posting
videos on YouTube I gained a total of
88,000 sub subscribers the second year I
gained over 600,000 subscribers and so
far this year I've done over 1.1 million
subscribers and so the more you do the
better you get and to give you another
extreme example because I mentioned my
podcast earlier my first two years of
podcasting I got to a total of 2,000
downloads a month and just fast forward
to now 6 years in I get about 2 million
downloads a month so these things can
compound they just take time the second
thing that I learned is SC in the
unscalable so she has famously been
known for appearing randomly at some of
her fans
weddings to play songs for them everyone
loses their mind all the iPhones come
out and then she goes viral on the
internet for a few days a newly wet
couple got a surprise Wedding Crasher
that they wouldn't dare to turn away I
am not a worldclass performer and I'm
probably not going to be able to perform
at someone's wedding but how can I take
what Taylor did in scaling the
unscalable in that micro example and
apply to what I do every so often I'll
do a sporadic Q&A live with people in
our audience in mosy nation what do I do
for a living I invest in advised
businesses so what's a micro version of
that I can invest invise somebody who
would never really have access to me in
any other capacity and so I can still
take that and then multiply to thousands
of other people because it scale
something that otherwise is unscalable I
couldn't talk one-onone to every single
person in my audience it' be impossible
she can't show up at every person's
wedding but she can still simulate the
experience and to the same degree for me
the reason I put out all this free
content and I put out all my books and
my Audi books and the courses and
they're all free and I do that because
that's something that allows me to take
a lot of energy put it into one thing
and then distribute it to everyone the
third thing that I love from Taylor
vulnerability even in her songs
themselves she showcases her heart and
her looking like the fool or the crazy
person more times than not and so it
Happ happens is she becomes still
despite being the superstar that she is
relatable at the lowest level to the
girl that's still singing in her
hairbrush into the mirror because they
experience the same feelings Taylor does
the many flaws and pitfalls and
heartbreaks that she's had over her
entire career and just showing them to
the public rather than trying to hide
them Taylor then instead of having
something that everyone can attack flips
it into a power because if you attack
her for that you attack her entire fan
base for experiencing the same thing and
so she builds an army of people that
will defend her because they resonate
with the experience that she shared
Taylor Swift fans may have taken her hit
song Shake It Off too literally yeah it
actually caused the equivalent of a 2.3
magnitude earthquake and it lasted
several hours that's a new record okay
Alex how are you vulnerable all the
stories I tell the vast majority of them
are me up and losing all my
money twice she talks about
relationships and love a lot and so her
equivalent of bankruptcy and losing
everything is is getting her heartbroken
and so for me I talk about the first
time I whiffed on a sale the first time
I trusted a partner didn't work the
first time I had all my money stolen the
second time I had my money stolen the
multiple businesses that I had to shut
down when I had nine businesses and had
to shut eight of them down so that I
could go all in on one these are all
stories that aren't like the fun cover
of Forbes instead they're just like hey
I also was a small business owner and
made a lot of mistakes that you might
too and so for another small business
owner who hears that they might be like
I've been there too and then it takes
something that seems crazy and
unattainable like a multi million doll
portfolio and makes it relatable thing
number four from Tay Tay I'm just going
to put ownership so one of the things
that Taylor has done differently than
many musicians is that she's a shrewd
businesswoman it's also why she's top 20
on Forbes for wealthiest women in
general which she doesn't talk about as
much but girl knows how to make money
her last a Tour gross over a billion
dollars on one tour so what she's done
is she independently publishes her stuff
and this has been something I think
she's worked towards because in the
beginning she sold our music and she had
to buy it back lots of drama but she has
moved towards this action and because
now she has more money and she has more
leverage because she has such a big
audience she can negotiate different
deals that other people wouldn't be able
to and it's like okay Alex well how do I
do something like that or how did you do
something like that right off the bat I
could have gone to a regular publisher
to publish all my books like that would
have been pretty much the normal path
for the business influencer who wants to
get the New York Times best seller
whatever and so for me I give away
chapter left and right I make it free on
my podcast no Publishers like wait I
want to buy the rights to your book so
that you can only give it away for free
but I want to do that and so in order to
maintain control I maintained ownership
over my stuff because even in the short
term I could have taken a few million
dollar check from a publisher just up
front to write the book but I'd so much
rather own it for the rest of my life
and be able to give it away as I see fit
because I know at least for me
conditions change and me trying to make
a decision today for something that I'm
going to have to live with for the rest
of my life feels steep even though it
probably hurts more in the short term
which is why so many musicians and
creators do sign away all their rights
too early because the people who have
been there before have seen a hundred
other creators go through it and they
know it's going to happen but if you can
have the stomach to be patient and
actually believe that you're going to go
all the way then it never makes sense to
sell and so the last one that I learned
from Taylor was shifting identity now a
different way of saying this is that her
brand has shifted over time yet she's
gone from a country music player to the
girl who chases boys and gets her
heartbroken to then just becoming this
powerful woman today and so she's shed
her identity multiple times and
transformed her brand multiple times
into what it is today and I would say
that the Aeros tour for example is a
great exemplify of her leaning into this
idea that she has set eras in her life
today I didn't wear a nose strip what
does that mean it just means I didn't
wear a nose STP today and that's okay I
don't actually have my hat on today
either why am I doing that does it mean
that I'm making some big statement about
it no I just want to be me and if I ever
feel like I have to dress the part to be
on camera I don't want any part of it
play it out if I then become beloved for
something that I'm forcing myself into
then what I'm doing is I'm portraying
something that's other than myself for
people to fall in love with as I change
and grow I will grow further and further
away from the thing that people love
which means that I will have to feel
more and more like a fraud I will have
to fake it and pretend more and more as
more people fall in love with this Idol
that I've created that's not even real
and so for me if I decide to change my
shoes one day I'm going to change my
shoes I'm not going to say well my whole
audience expects me to wear Crocs I
don't wear Crocs by the way anymore I
think this is one of the beautiful
things that creators have and that us as
individuals have it's embracing who you
are which I think she's done
unbelievably well and staying true to
that North Star rather than what critics
want her to be and she's even changed
that way in her music and she's like you
know what I'm just going to be me that's
what her audience is in love with her
being her because she gives them
permission to be themselves and if
you're curious you belong with me is my
favorite talor Swift
song This Is The Rock This is a
life-size cutout of him yes I am huge
but not as huge as the Rocks net worth
which just cross multiple billions of
dollars based on his stake in teram
Tequila here are four things I learned
from from The Rock first thing right off
the bat is the same thing that I got
from Tay which is longevity do you know
how long the rock has been the rock I
mean we even call him the rock but he's
Dwayne Johnson and some people don't
even know that he got his career started
as a WWE wrestler he started his career
in 1996 some of you guys watching this
weren't even a glimmer in your father's
eye in 1996 so Point number one is
longevity Point number two is work ethic
one of the things that Dwayne Johnson
has made himself famous for for is how
early he shows up to sets how late he
will stay and how he never misses a
workout no matter what he's he flies
into China it's 4 in the morning he's
lifting weights like what the when
he started his career he started at the
bottom of the totem hole in WWE the guy
that everyone beat up and he had to show
up and work twice as hard the same story
as Kobe Bryant of like if they work out
once if I work out three times I'll just
get better faster he wasn't born this
way and even 5 years into that career he
wasn't Dwayne Johnson The
multi-billionaire icon he wasn't even
still can you smell what The Rock is
cooking yet
[Applause]
like but the Rock is cooking he hadn't
really even reached the the peak or the
Zenith of his startom it took a long
time for him to get there and he was
able to stomach it because of his work
ethic and so how do I apply this to me I
have always taken the position that I
work from the moment I wake up until the
moment I literally can't work anymore
especially on the come up and so work
from 4:00 a.m. until 10: and then from
10:00 a.m. on I would do my actual work
with other people and so I couldn't get
the work I wanted to get done done
during the day cuz I had to run the
business and so I would do it before
everyone else was up you have to work
double time you got to work the job that
you have today but in the mornings or
the late evenings you build for the job
you want to have tomorrow when I say job
I have a job too today even though I own
the businesses that we're a part of I
still have a job to do and so that job
is doing what you have to do today and
building for what you want to have
tomorrow even my current season I spend
6 hours a day every day writing so that
I can publish books on a regular Cadence
and so my last book $ million leads I
spent 6 hours a day for almost two years
writing that book and same thing for
offers and now with XYZ secret book
that's coming out I'm doing the same
thing the first thing every day before I
came in today here to film this with you
I edited my book for the first four
hours of the day so the third thing I
learned from the rock is expanding
niches he became one of the most if not
the most famous WD wrestler of all time
now he could have stopped there but he
had bigger aspirations and so over his
career he has continued to widen and bro
in what he's Associated himself with
right in the very very beginning he was
a football player then he spun that into
the wrestling career and then he took
that to the Natural maximum and then
from there he started making movies but
what did he start with he started with
roles that required him to be in really
good shape and show off that he was in
it if you remember his first two movies
the money returns and the later Scorpion
King where he was actually a main
character in that one he was there
pretty much to show off his physique no
one else in Hollywood is doing that not
Tom Cruz not Will
Smith now he's in Disney movies so he's
gone from being a really high level
football player to being bottom of the
totem WWE to top of WWE to low low in
the movie scene to high in the movie
scene as an action career to the
broadest base that you can have because
when you get into Disney movies at that
point you're catering to everyone
following the strategy has made him
among and if not the highest paid actor
today and so for me you're like okay
well how did you expand your Niche well
I started as just a dude who was in
shape and then people started com in and
be like hey can you help me get in shape
and I was like sure I guess and then
somebody literally handed me money
without me asking and I was like oh wow
I guess I could make money doing this so
then I got into the business of helping
getting people in shape and then I was
like maybe I could open a gym so then I
opened a gym and then I started doing
well with the gym and then people who
own gyms were like hey can you help me
run my gym and I was like I guess so I
don't know if this is business and then
again literally someone handed me ,000
and said launch my gym and I said I
guess so and then I took that to 5,000
locations and then from there it was
like hey how did you expand this BWB
licensing thing so you went National
businesses of that size started to
approach me and that has literally been
my entire career do something really
well people ask me about it and then I
say okay well I'll show you how I did
that and each of these transitions has
actually been forced every single time
someone literally handed me money and
said can you do it and I was like I
guess so and then that's how it started
so on the topic of money the fourth
thing I've learned from The Rock
monetization so The Rock has spent the
first 20 plus years of his career not
really monetizing his direct brand now
he was in movies he obviously gets paid
to do that he was paid to be in the WWE
but he didn't really own anything that
he was able to really push and then all
of a sudden in the last three or four
years he came out with zoa which is the
energy drink and supplement line he came
out with project rock with Under Armour
which was a collaboration between him
and them and he came out with teramana
the tequila and his slice of teramana I
believe is 30% stake in the company
which is now valued over $6 billion he's
been very strategic about the highest
leverage ways that he can monetize his
brand without deluding who he is we've
all seen those actresses who come out
with an alcohol line now and they don't
even drink or they come out with makeup
and they actually are known for their
natural look things that just obviously
don't make sense now what do people fall
in love with a rock for they love the
fact that he works super hard but he
also has cheat days on Sunday he also
sips his tequila and was doing that for
a very regular basis and people knew he
loved tequila and so it made sense for
him because it wasn't a change it was
just reinforcing more of what he already
was and so if you think about how you
want to monetize you want it to be more
of what you already are and this is
where people miss the mark they're like
what's the thing that I can sell to the
most people or what's the thing that's
got the highest ticket it has to
reinforce the association that people
have come to love about you and so in
studying The Rock and setting some of
these other influencers what I'm paying
a lot of attention to is how they're
choosing to monetize Tastefully how do I
monetize Tastefully well I own companies
and so when companies consume my stuff
and learn and grow and make more money
then they hit me up and say hey Alex can
you help me grow and scale my company
and invest and I say sure if they're
awesome and if they're not I just say
just enjoy all the other stuff I don't
need 25 Facebooks I just need one and so
I'm okay with the fact that 99.9% of
people will only quote take for me and
not give anything back and I'm cool with
that it's the same reason it would be
weird if I came out with a luxury watch
line or a suit line of three-piece suits
that would be completely off brand now
do a lot of my people in my audience
probably wear suits and do business yes
would that be a high ticket item I could
probably make a lot of money on yes does
it make sense for my brand no and so
that's the idea is that we have these
associations that people have come to
love you for and then to go counter that
just to make money everyone sees it and
then they lose trust with you you can
file bankruptcy when you go way too far
into debt and then you can start over
but you can't file bankruptcy on a
reputation once it's ruined it's ruined
for life and it takes a very long time
to build one and a very short time to
lose one and so if you ever have the
choice between reputation and money
always choose reputation because this
one you can't get back you can always
make more money all right the rock now
we're going to Mr
Beast so first things first that I
learned from uh Mr Beast was his
longevity and you're going to hear me
keep repeating this and the reason I say
it is because everyone keeps comparing
themselves to someone's 10th year
starting was what 13 what's up guys OV
excited generic YouTuber here he's 11
years in of doing this at an obsessive
rate I feel like there's there's two
stages in most people's career there's
the time they start and the time they
get serious he happened to do both on
the same time and so if you can decrease
the time between when you start and when
you commit you'll start seeing the
benefits of commitment sooner like I see
so many people who got into fitness
and they say I've been training for 5
years and I say have you been training
for 5 years or do you have you been
going to the gym on and off for 5 years
and they're like well I've been training
for 6 months I've been going on and off
for four and a half years and I'm like
well then the first four and a half
years was literally just to prepare you
for the first 6 months of taking this
seriously you're only 6 months into your
working out career not 5 years and so
they then compare themselves to somebody
5 years to be like why am I not there
it's like you're really only 6 months in
Go Pro be a professional and take it
like your job number two and this is a
big one this is super tactical so I was
having a conversation with Mr Beast and
I was like we're not trying to make you
know clickbait videos we going to make
stuff that people feel is you know
really high quality Etc and he looked at
me and he just looked at like I had four
heads and he was like you absolutely
make clickbait videos he's like you just
need to make the clickbait
true and it was such a great mindset
shift for me because when I think about
marketing I think about the same way if
you want to Market a product make the
crazy claim but back up the crazy claim
and some of you guys have been
commenting that we've kind of upped our
game on our videos and a lot of it comes
from this Frame of Mind of like how can
you make an insane claim and back it up
with an even more insane video number
three is doubling down the day he
started was the day he went pro he said
he was either going to become a pro
YouTuber or he wasn't going to do
anything at all and he has shown that
with his actions as he makes more money
he puts all of it back into the next
videos and he has consistently done that
since day one and if anything his
current Channel still runs as a quote
nonprofit in that it's not profitable
because he actually chooses to monetize
elsewhere through febles and Beast
burger and some of his other Ventures he
has continued to reinvest in his
compounding vehicle and you'll notice
compounding is a common theme among all
these people that we're talking about is
that he took the extra rather than
putting his pocket he said what if I put
it back on black again and it is very
much a gamble but if you know what
you're doing you become the house so for
me personally I have been willing to
double down on my career and make big
bets that otherwise didn't make sense my
first career as a consultant most people
said oh you should go do more of that
but I took all my learnings from being a
consultant and then started a gym which
was a a big bet for me but I was
doubling down on what I beli to be true
then I scaled my gyms to six locations
and then I just basically walked away
from them I fire sold them in 90 days
and then started the licensing business
and from there doubled down there until
now we now have acquisition. comom our
portfolio of companies even when I was
thinking about selling gym launch so
many people are like dude you have this
amazing business that you don't have to
do anything for that prints you out
millions of dollars a month in personal
income what is wrong with you why would
you sell because the thing is is that
they will project their goals onto your
reality and as long as your reality is
above their goals they will not
understand you and so if you have big
goals then you only have to listen to
you because whatever yours is if you
satisfied their check mark it's like I
satisfied you not me and so being
willing to double down and burn the
boats and pursue the dream that you
actually want is risky but in my opinion
when I die and I look back well when I
die I won't be able to look back but
right before I die
and I look back I will be so much more
proud of the failures that I risked than
the successes that I didn't and the
fourth thing that I learned from Mr
Beast was packaging specifically around
media I watched Sam take apart someone
else's video and in the first 5 seconds
he said stop the video and this is
somebody who had already had 10 million
views on the video and was upset that
they didn't have 30 million views and he
said oh you didn't match the thumbnail
to the first 5 Seconds you didn't
confirm it he was like well that's it
he's like I don't need to watch any more
of the video that's why it's not a 30
million view video and it was such a
tiny tactical detail but it made such a
massive difference in the amount of
views I now appreciate how important how
you package the content you have so for
example some of you guys have noticed
that we run split tests on the
thumbnails and the reason for that is
that there's two things we look at one
is how many people click but then how
long people who click based on that
watch and you'd be amazed that there's
sometimes 20 30% increases in the amount
of time that someone will watch simply
based on how the video was framed and so
for us we want to make real business
education accessible for everyone and
making it accessible for everyone means
that we have to package it in a way that
makes it attractive to everyone and
fulfills the promises that we made in
the packaging I made a video a long time
ago about luxury goods now the whole
video is just about understanding how
luxury goods fits within a pricing
Matrix in a marketpl sounds kind of
boring but I was like huh how can I
package this in a way that would make it
more accessible for more people and
recently Bernard or know who owns lvmh
Which is a holding company that owns
many many luxury brands that you've
heard of flash them on the screen he had
just recently become the richest man and
so I was like oh this is relevant how
did he become the richest man through
luxury goods and just doing that
dramatically improved how many people
would benefit from the video because it
became timely it became trending and he
was around someone who already
demonstrated that he was a viable
business model and the last one I want
to hit on from Jim is resourcefulness
now a lot of people see him today as the
person who spends a million dollars on
every video and he's giving all this
money away and they're like I could
never copy Jimmy and you're right you
can't today but what you can copy is the
things that he did to get here and so
his first ever viral video was him
counting up as high as he could and I
think he got to 100,000 plus now how
much did that cost nothing just
imagination and as soon as he made
$110,000 from that video he gave it to a
homeless guy this is not clickbait I'm
going to give a random homeless guy
$10,000 today and then that video went
viral he's consistently just said how
can I use what I have which if you
follow any of my content the first rule
of entrepreneur ship is use what you've
got and he has exemplified that in his
content and so how do you relate this to
me well when I started I didn't have the
big media team that I have today it was
just me and a webcam and then from there
we're like okay let's get one with just
like some lights in a professional
camera and then it was like okay I'm
actually going to have a videographer
here present with me when I do these
videos and then it was like you know
what we might actually edit the videos
rather than just trimming out the front
and the end and the ums it didn't make
sense for me at the beginning to have a
massive media team because I didn't know
what I was doing and so as we've gotten
better we've gotten better and we've
used the resources we have to continue
to grow the team so we can make more
stuff for you guys I would recommend not
beating yourself up for the fact that
you don't have resources but learning
the skill of
resourcefulness which you will need
throughout the entirety of your career
because at every level you have to
always be resourceful and if you don't
learn how to be resourceful when you
have nothing you're not going to be
resourceful when you have everything
thanks Jim appreciate that and the
chocolate bars check out febles by the
way
right off the bat what did I learn from
Joe longevity you're like wow Alex why
do you keep saying that because it
matters all right I keep
repeating it because not one of these
people is an overnight success all these
are decade plus successes and most of
them are multi- deade successes Joe
started doing stand-up comedy in Boston
in 1988 and for many of my audience you
also weren't alive then on top of that
he got his first real break when he
started doing Fear Factor which is a
show where he's basically mcing girls
getting rats thrown into a tub with them
where they have to keep their mouth open
Joe's had the humility throughout his
entire career to be willing to do
whatever it took and I don't think when
he was a little kid was like I want to
be a star he was like I'm going to go MC
girls in bikinis uh having bees all
around them dripping with honey I don't
think he thought that but he was willing
to take the opportunities to presented
itself and he's been willing to stick
with it for a very very long time second
thing I've learned from Joe you know
what I think this is important enough
that I'm I'm going to put it on here
because he has restarted his career at
zero multiple times like he was a
standup comedian but then he's doing
mcing for a TV show he probably wasn't
as good as he is now when he does it for
the UFC one of the biggest sports in the
world he was willing to be humble and do
it and suck and that's why so many
losers lose is because they're not
willing to lose they cannot accept
sucking and so they always lose by
default because they never start yeah
until you win no one pays attention to
you get used to it and the reason people
look like overnight successes is because
you just happen to find out about them
when they hit it and so you just Mark
the fact that when you find out about
them is when they started doing it which
is ridiculous but it's a cognitive bias
just because you experience the world
that way doesn't mean it's true so for
me I have basically restarted my career
multiple times probably the biggest
slice of humble pie that I've had to eat
was going from being a white collar
consultant on my way to Harvard to being
a personal trainer at a local gym so not
even an owner or a manager a Frontline
trainer getting paid minimum wage and so
when you go from a sixf fig job to a
minimum wage job your status changes a
lot and that was tough for me but I knew
how miserable I was doing the thing that
I didn't like and I believed that this
wasn't what I was going to be doing for
the rest of my life and I knew that for
me this was a season of learning not
earning and so I never thought I was
going to be stuck at minimum wage I just
knew that I felt like I was just getting
paid to learn so I was like I would pay
to be here so the fact that they're
paying me is just a great deal for me
because the thing is is you compare
yourself today at Day Zero whereas what
I left I was probably at year six in
terms of like all the things I did to
get there I had to prep for SATs to get
into Vanderbilt to graduate in three
years to have be president and vice
president of the The Power Team
president of the fraternity and then do
all the case study stuff so I could get
the consulting job and did that for two
years and then prep for the gats like I
was six years into that career but I
started over at zero because I just
wanted something else and all of you
guys who are watching this right now
you're watching this personal brand
being built and all this content that
they putting out I just learned this
stuff like 2 or 3 years ago right now I
started making my podcast six years ago
but for three years I didn't do anything
else besides my podcast but I didn't
really go pro on making content until
the end of 2019 2020 I didn't know
anything and so I hired people and was
like hey can you tell me they're like
you suck and I'm like yeah I'm aware of
that and I told the first guy that I
heard for YouTube I said I'm willing to
do this for 10 years and I was like if
it doesn't work after 10 years I was
like I'll stop and when we obviously
took it in house he said on the way out
he was like I just want you to know that
you changed my entire perspective
because I've never had a single person
tell me that they were willing to wait a
decade for something to work he's like
every other person who comes to me is
like how do I get 100K subscribers 90
days and it's unsurprising now that we
actually probably have a bigger
subscriber base than anybody he'd ever
worked with because we approached it
differently I'm just willing to suck
because I believe that if someone else
can get good at it so can I number three
this is probably probably the most
important one you are the niche I want
to be really
clear there's a difference between
having a personal brand and building a
brand in a business building a brand in
a business is going to be around the
products you sell and the Avatar or the
audience that you Market to so if you
want to build content for a specific
business that sells widgets then it
should be probably people using that
widget within the context they would use
it in but you building a personal brand
should be true to the person just like
you're being true to the product and be
Encompass all the things that you really
are what is Joe Rogan's
Niche is it politics but then he does
all this biohacking stuff okay was it
Fitness well then he talks about aliens
like a lot okay well is it fighting cuz
he's really deep into fighting but he's
also a big time standup comedian well
shoot what is it it's none of them and
it's all of them it's Joe Rogan because
if I said all of those things together
hey what big celebrity do you know who's
into biohacking aliens politics
technology fighting and comedy you'd be
like Joe Rogan because that's his unique
thumbprint now all of those are
different categories and in different
proportions so for example he's got
health and he's got comedy well on his
show which of them takes up a greater
percentage well he probably talks more
about biohacking and health and things
that are going on in the in the total us
around Health compared to Comedy now he
still has comedians on his show and
talks about comedy stuff but the
proportion is different so not only is
it the number of categories but it's the
proportion between the categories that
makes the unique thumbprint of the
creator point being if you're building a
personal brand speak to things that you
know and if you're like well I don't
know very much you start with the one
you know cuz you've lived your life up
to this point and you spent time one way
or another which means that there are
things that are unique to you that you
are deeper on than somebody on the
street and one of the hardest parts
about this and this is me just being
real with you is that if you know it
really well you actually assume everyone
does if you were raised around cars for
example and your dad was a mechanic or
you just like love that stuff you
probably know a lot more about cars than
the average person I don't know anything
about cars I'm not really that
interested in
but there are people who are and so you
making content about the things that you
actually care about you will be
knowledgeable and there's a difference
between telling people what they should
do and sharing the things that you know
it's subtle but one is preaching one is
teaching and you want to be the teacher
not the preacher I think one of the
things that he has given me permission
to do is talk about all the things that
I am interested in cuz I spoke to many
people and they're like dude don't talk
about your like death phosy stuff it's
like really dark
and they're like just just talk about
money stuff but if you're going to be
talking money stuff you should wear a
suit because you want to look that part
but I don't I don't dress that way I
dress like this but they're you're going
to look like a meathead so then which of
these things is Alex rosi all of them
none of them at the same time your brand
will be stronger based on how closely it
matches who you really are and the
things that you genuinely care about and
as those things change so too should
your brand to reflect that rather than
say oh I had a mustache for 5 years
which by the way I did I had a big
Gunslinger mustache for 5 years and
everything that was public had a
gunslinger mustache and then I was like
you know what kind of want to do a beard
so I put a beard on and so what happened
to my brand it changed but that was okay
because that's who I was then and this
is who I am now and maybe in the future
I'll shave one day and you know what
I'll still be me and so if you want to
measure the strength of a single person
in your audience in relation to your
brand it's how many interest that you
have that a person in your audience
shares or overlaps with if I like
politics and fighting and comedy and
health and Aliens I'm probably going to
love Joe Rogan on the flip side if I
don't like any of those things but I
kind of like Health then I might kind of
like Joe Rogan because I don't like the
majority of the other stuff he talks
about and so taking this into my
personal context if someone likes
training calvs they like desserts they
like being in shape they like business
in making money they like
philosophy they're probably going to
like my stuff and some of the business
people are like dude I wish you could
just only make business content I was
like but that's not me cuz I don't only
talk about business but the point is is
that like I don't want to shy away from
who I am so that I can meet some
artificially generated algorithm
character that doesn't really exist and
I think that in the short term if I did
that I probably would win in the short
term but in the long term I would resent
who that character become because they
had been become so far away for who I
really am and then I would feel like a
fraud and then you would see it in my
content because I wouldn't feel legit
number four is that Joe only talks about
sponsorships he believes in now he
obviously is equity in some of the
companies that he promotes though he had
a big exit with on it uh which is a
multi million do supplement brand that
he basically pioneered and Alpha Brain
the product that he talked about a lot
when we came up with alpab brain it was
the first one that I ever tried that I
was like this is like a very clear
difference but he's in a position where
he could get oh my God if if FTX wanted
him to to promote their products I'm
sure they did he could have made a
massive check from them for promoting it
but he didn't believe in it so he said
no and so a lot of what he's defined
himself by is all the things that he
only truly wants to win so he only
promotes stuff that he actually wants to
win and he believes in and you can hear
it in the endorsements that he gives
he's like I use this stuff and so I'm
letting you know about it I take uh a a
a giant athletic greens every day and
doesn't come across salesy he just lets
you know why he takes it and so in my
opinion the thing that I've learned from
Joe is that you want to promote things
that are minimal changes in your
behavior so ideally you exist exactly
the way you were before except you just
happen to get paid for something that
you would already be willing to tell
someone about now that massively limits
the amount of things that you can
promote but that's okay because you
don't want to be these people who just
shill 100 things because by doing that
you also dilute the brand that you have
because everyone knows it's not you
because no one's interested in 100
things you might only be interested in 2
3 4 maybe five things and that's
probably what you should limit your
quote brand bullets to and the fifth one
is no hacks all right this is so so big
because you can think about Joe is
almost the anti- algorithm it just says
episode whatever and the name of the
guest and he doesn't cut all the stuff
so he can make it the most action- pack
scene he just lets it cut unedited raw
and uploads it his Instagram he says he
subscribed to post and ghost which is he
posts it and then he ghosts it they're
not optimized he just uses the platform
as somebody who uses the platform and
people choose to follow him because they
are interested in what he is interested
in so he is interesting because he is
interested if you look at every one of
these celebrities if you look at their
social media it doesn't look like
they're influencers but they have more
followers than almost all the
influencers put together that are what I
would consider the hacky and influencers
always trying to like algorithm hop or
Trend hop you don't see Rogan hopping on
the Taylor Swift trend for his Instagram
he just is Joe I get approached by so
many people who DM me saying hey man I
don't think your LinkedIn is optimized
hey I don't think your your Instagram is
optimized for growth hey I can do a
shout out for shout out let's do a
giveaway to do 20,000 followers 50,000
followers whatever it is none of those
build brand they are simply trying to
exploit an artificial hole or
inefficiency
in how an algorithm works and if you
base your brand on algorithm
exploitation you're basing it on a flaw
in a system that will get fixed and so
what you want to do in my opinion is
that you want to align what you make
with what the platform wants rather than
what the platform doesn't want and you
hacking around it what the platform
wants is for you to make engaging
content that an audience finds
interesting so they stay on the platform
that's it and so the best way to make
interesting content is to talk about the
things you are interested in if if you
post things that are real for you you
will be real for your audience rather
than just some that surfed on their
Newsfeed that they can immediately go to
your feed and see that all you do is
Trend hop which means that you actually
don't exist at
all Kylie was actually the last in
the armor for me deciding to start
making content and the reason for that
was she got the cover of Forbes as a
quote billionaire at age 20 and I saw
that and at the time I thought I was hot
for being a multi-millionaire and
when I saw her do that I have a
fundamental belief about business that
if someone makes more money than me they
are better at the game of business in
some way than I am and that I can learn
from them and the big difference between
what Kylie was doing and what I was
doing was her brand and she had built
that through content the first lesson
that I'll say that I have learned from
klie was yet again longevity because yes
she has a billion dollar brand and she's
very young but guess how young she
started being on National television she
appeared on National Television for the
first time 20 years ago on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians as a little bitty
itty bitty gy girl yeah yeah yeah going
she's been in the game two decades and
so as much as she is young she still has
put time under the bar and if you see a
common theme for all these people even
the youngest people here have at least a
decade and often multiple decades under
their belts so staying with it for a
long term yet again rules the day number
two is that she showed me Leverage now
leverage in multiple ways number one is
that she is leveraged from her family
she hangs out with other people who are
famous one of the easiest ways to get
more exposure is to hang out with people
who already have exposure and she did
that early on and has done that
throughout her career number one number
two is that she uses media she record
something one time and millions and
millions of people can see it and so by
using that she gets more for what she
puts in and so that's being able to
accelerate her career number three is
that based on the actual products that
she has chosen to sell with her brand
she does does things that scale and so
imagine if she was selling a tax service
it'd be very difficult for her to scale
that to her audience but if she sells a
lip kit she can make a gazillion of
those the only real constraint on that
would be capital and she's got that and
so she was able to get a high leverage
brand with a huge audience that she
built with a long time and media and
funnel it into something that has a lot
of Leverage that she built one time and
then could print over and over and over
again to her entire audience just simply
the business she chose to select
was one that better suited a mass Market
B Toc brand a lot of creators make the
wrong mistake here I see guys starting a
restaurant when they have a national
brand not to say that you won't make
money it's just that you won't make as
much money as you otherwise could in a
better vehicle number three is that she
outsources her weaknesses so the things
that she is in charge of is the product
and the marketing so she cares a lot
about the lip kits and she cares a lot
about the messaging and how things
appear and how she disseminates and
promotes it but everything else that
she's not an expert at she's probably
not an expert at third party Logistics
she's probably not an expert at actually
manufacturing stuff she's probably not
an expert at running warehouses she's
probably not an expert at even building
websites but based on the brand that she
has and the success of the company she
has we could probably make a leap of
faith to say that she's pretty good at
product and she's also pretty good
promoting and so by doing the things
that she's good at she's been willing to
give up some of the pie to other people
who have that expertise so she can
leverage the fact that somebody else has
years in third party Logistics partners
with them and to be fair this is
something you see across the Kardashians
they do very well is that they don't try
and own the entirety of the pie they say
how can we all win here and I'll take
this from the late Charlie Munger I
don't need every last dollar because he
believed that it's either a good deal or
it isn't and if it's a great deal I'm
going to make a ton of money and if it's
not he doesn't need to Chisel away
percentage points and I think I've seen
that across all of the Kardashians and
how they structure their deals they're
willing to let other people in to
leverage 20 years of experience to not
have to start over at Ground Zero they
start at year 20 on someone else's
career because of all the learnings and
connections that person has so that they
can just jump that much further forward
because I don't know about you but I'd
rather own 20% of a 20 billion company
than 100% of a million dollar company
and number four is that she Embraces
controversy they have time and again
leaned into what other people deem as
controversial and ridden the wave of
attention that it brings with it Kylie
and her entire family has been willing
to do that now that being said I
wouldn't say that I've completely
embraced this one entirely because I
don't really talk about much
controversial stuff besides poor people
should stop doing poor people stuff they
start following what rich people do and
do more rich people stuff but besides
that not a lot of controversy and so
maybe I need to do better there but
these are things that I think have
helped build and Propel her brand at a
faster rate than other people the next
one is that she's adaptable but she's
been able to adapt as media platforms
have changed and so it was television
once and then they went from television
to Hulu which is online TV they went all
in on Instagram really really early and
started making content there on a
regular basis and their content looks
very different from the classic
influencers their content feeds into
their brand as super famous people and
they continue to reinforce that with the
luxury Brands they've all done deals
with and the products they promote
themselves and the next one is that she
is accessible and this may be even her
superpower and this is partially because
she's in the makeup industry she leaned
into just being who she was and so she
would do Instagram lives and stories
where it was just her no makeup despite
what the media May portray them as is
making false and unrealistic
expectations for girls I think that what
they actually make in their content is
probably the exact opposite of that they
show the 16 hours that it took them to
get ready for the Met Gala and all of
these things that they do where they
have to paint the stuff onto them or
they have to not be able to go to the
bathroom for 3 hours because of the
stuff that they're wearing they show
that stuff so that they become more
accessible so that people who relate to
that also want to buy their their
products and so you might see all these
things and be like how did you use this
Alex one I started posting content in
general because I saw how much she had
made and I was like I am missing this
whole concept of brand and started
leaning into it number two is that I
would say that leverage literally is
part of our logo and it's one of the
things that I talk about all the time
it's something that I believe a lot in
Outsourcing weaknesses that's why you
hire great people every single time I
built one of these channels out I don't
try and learn a new platform I find
somebody already knows it and I pay them
to teach me so that I can learn faster
I'm not good at embracing controversy
but but in terms of adaptability and
accessibility we have continued to go
into new platforms as fast as we can and
as fast as they come out so that we can
experiment and we're willing to have
stuff that absolutely flops and I think
that's cool because we learn and finally
the accessibility piece is even though
in the beginning it was a webcam and it
was just me in a closet making videos
I'd rather start with what I have than
try and portray the life that I have cuz
I went from being really rich and
Anonymous saying you know what maybe
I'll make some videos
to making lots of stuff and making it
look really polished and highly produced
but it didn't happen overnight and I
think that mosy nation has appreciated
just watching the journey the whole way
through just as they've probably
appreciated watching her journey even
though they know that she could put
filters on or could only hop on
Instagram live once she's done all of
her makeup like I could probably Flex
more of my material belongings than I do
uh because I just don't think that would
serve anyone and so that's why I don't
so I've learned that from them now
obviously she flexes a little bit on her
material belong but you know tomato
tomato everyone's got different brands
I'm not going to come out with a lip kit
anytime soon so that's her brand not
mine so my brand has evolved over the
ages you can call this mosy through time
and this is me as 23 years old really
into fitness and just starting my first
gym here I'm much older as somebody
who's the master gym licenser you know I
have 5,000 Plus locations I'm building
gym launch which is a company that's B2B
servicing gym owners and then over here
you've got mosy today who is the
managing partner of a private Equity
Firm called acquisition. comom that owns
a bunch of companies and so the question
is how does a brand as a personal brand
evolve over time in the beginning look
how I dressed I've got my neon tank top
and I've got my neon shorts and the
reason that I dress this way is because
one this is how I actually dressed cuz I
was into fitness but also I had a 70%
female audience I needed to look
approachable not like a big scary dude
me today probably not something that
most women are going to be like yes I'm
going to trust him in my weight loss
Journey they're like I don't want to
look like you and you have a beard no
thank you right but this looks like a
relatively approachable young man who's
high energy and filled with the Light Of
Hope all I was focused on was Fitness
Nutrition and accountability I was
listening to Rihanna on Tuesdays that I
was cranking inside of the gym and I had
women's only playlist and I was catering
to the audience that I had at that time
and me in reality was this person all I
was thinking about was Fitness and
anyways and really just trying to get my
career going as an entrepreneur now fast
forward here when I'm the master
licenser if I was this guy the audience
that I have here is 90% male and not
only 90% male 90% jacked male gym owners
so look how my personal brand changed
now I want to be clear it's not like
every time I did this it was the most
deliberate thing it was just that I also
changed over time because what happened
is here all I was thinking about was
Fitness I had just been competing I had
a few State records I was following
periodization I was counting my macros
every day it was what I was obsessed
with at the time which is why I started
a business around Fitness but that
second part a business around Fitness
started to become the most important
part to me which is why over time I
started caring more and more about
business and less and less about Fitness
and so then I became the gym Lord which
was the name of our community which is
gym Lords and so I started wearing the
stuff that repped my new company and
most most the people that followed my
stuff then believe it or not I was a lot
cruder about making money back then than
I am now because remember this was the
guy who wanted to be rich and Anonymous
you will probably grow and change in
your interests and the way you dress and
the way you look also changed that way
now I think there's a biral relationship
I changed and so so did my audience
which also changed me back my pants are
falling down I have to blur that out so
I'll call out two things that were very
specific about this number one was that
I called it originally gym rescue and as
soon as I got on the phone with people
people were like I don't be rescued I
don't need to be rescued and then their
egos would flare up so I was like oh no
what if we just launch your gym like
we're doing a grand opening and they're
like okay yeah yeah that's cool even
though they've been open for 5 years but
when I called it a launch everyone was
fine with it so then I switched my
language from gym rescue to gym launch
because of my audience not because of
what I wanted kind of interesting the
second thing is you'll notied that I
went from brigh eyed and bushy tailed
kid here to man with a handlebar
mustache and so then the mustache became
part of the brand and I did that for the
entire of time that I was the gym Lord
and running gym launch so then what
happened is as I started making more and
more money I started seeing people
making even more money than me and it
was all these private Equity guys and I
was like this guy bought a company for
50 million sold it for 250 made 200
million didn't even have to start the
company and so as my interest started to
evolve because I started investing more
and I started buying real estate I
started buying businesses and I was like
huh there's a game beyond the game and I
actually started moving away from being
the gym Lord because I didn't want to be
the face of that company more I just
wanted to be the owner and so this shift
was me going from operator to
owner and as an owner all I cared about
was my return on investment and making
sure that we were doing business in
alignment with our values and so I
started dressing how I would dress
without being public facing now the
irony of this whole thing is that in
dressing in a way that wasn't supposed
to be public facing I ended up becoming
even more public facing than I ever
thought and so over time the way that I
dress which is pretty much just the most
utilitarian way I can imagine look at
these caps and so this is mosy today and
there may be a mosy in the future who
dresses differently because I changed my
mind about stuff but the thing is is
that over the years I went from loving
Fitness to loving operating businesses
to loving owning and scaling companies
and my progression as an individual has
reflected in how I dressed and who I was
talking to but the point is is that I
think the only way to make a personal
brand last is for it to be you and I
want to be really clear here this is a
visual prop set and I'm using this
because people need visuals to
understand stuff but I will say that I
feel like this overemphasizes the
importance of a quote outfit it is not
that important if I start wearing black
tank tops tomorrow and I start wearing
sweats no one's going to give a
because my value is about the stuff that
I provide that helps the audience do
better helps hopefully you guys make
more money grow in the ways that you
want to grow achieve the goals you want
that's the value not how I dress it's
just that because I dress this way and I
do it consistently because that's who I
am people have then Associated that
value with this outfit which is why
someone else can wear my logo and people
will approach them and Associate the
value that I've given them with that
person and that's how you brand that's
how you build brand equity and so I show
this as a visual demonstration to give
you the idea but not to emphasize that
you have to wear a certain thing in
order to build your brand but if what
you wear is a representation of who you
are then it will probably have some
degree to that because people at least
at the onset will judge you by how you
look and just to give you guys some
context on why a private Equity investor
would be even be making a a YouTube
video and be explaining this topic so
number one is that notice how all these
people are all billionaires kind of
interesting why are they billionaires
what's different now versus what it was
before well now there's direct
distribution when Tom Hanks became
famous he didn't have direct
distribution so he always had to do
Partnerships with movie companies who
then did Partnerships with movie
theaters to distribute the content but
now because platforms came in between
the distribution and the end user
creators could immediately post directly
and interact with their entire audience
and so what that did is it cut out all
these middlemen and allowed creators to
take up a huge slice of the economics
and so me recognizing that in each of
these people is part of the reason that
I started even though I didn't need to
start making content because I saw the
value in the audience and just to give
you guys some hard stats around this on
why I decided to basically give up
anonymity which I do like my privacy one
is that this is according to Goldman
Sachs the crater economy is projected to
be at 500 billion half a trillion a year
plus by
2027 this is not far away this is 1 b500
times in a row every year that's a
that's a lot of billions and to give you
an idea of the audience size Instagram
has 2.3 billion and then YouTube has 2.6
billion users and Tik Tok has 1.6
billion these are all monthly active
users I mean this is the world and then
beyond that just to give you context in
terms of just USA YouTube alone creates
$25 billion a year in GDP for the United
States of America just from jobs that
were created by creators which right now
is over 400,000 jobs this is real
economics that are happening and
unfolding in front of our eyes how
business was traditionally done has been
turned on its head and when you see
teenagers and 20-year-olds becoming
decamillionaires ctim Millionaires and
billionaires pay attention because the
troll comments in this world are like if
you have so much money why are you
making these videos dumbass if I have so
much money why the do you think I'm
making the videos because there's value
in doing it beyond all of the obvious
ones which is you build an audience you
can sell things to them the larger one
that's unspoken is the access to other
people now if I want to reach out to a
public CEO and say hey can I hop on the
phone or hey do you want to do a podcast
the answer is yes because I have an
audience and so whatever their message
is it doesn't matter how rich you are if
you don't have someone listening you
can't distribute your message so you
might be sitting at home or at the gas
station or between things or you're on
the can right now thanks for joining me
and wondering okay I just saw some of
the biggest influencers of all time and
how they built their brands what am I
going to do now so what we're going to
use as a process rip Charlie merer
called inverted thinking so rather than
say hey here's the six steps to creating
your personal brand I want to talk about
the things that would would destroy a
personal brand or guarantee that you
never build one to begin with so let's
start off the top if I were to only do
this one thing what would I do to
guarantee that I can't build a brand
well number one is I would talk about
something that I know nothing about so
if you talk about stuff that you don't
know anything about and are not
interested in I can guarantee you will
not build a very good brand around that
topic next I would be inconsistent and
ideally not even start for fear of
judgment so let's call that quitting
slash start stop you can't stick with it
because even if your stuff was really
really good if you quit for a long time
or you start and you stop and you start
and you stop I can guarantee you you're
not going to build a big brand next
thing I would do is I would try and do
two things around selling one is I would
sell early so that means that I haven't
provided any value to my audience and I
immediately start trying to sell them
stuff I have very little Goodwill I
don't have a lot of people but because
I'm desperate for money I start trying
to sell stuff and I sell it really hard
well that'll probably destroy the brand
because people already have very little
affin towards you and now they have zero
so that would be one of the things I
would definitely do to make sure that we
destroy your brand the other thing is I
would sell
wrong and what I mean by that is that
I'd sell the wrong stuff and so if I'm
making stuff about gardening then I say
hey you should take this credit card
that has all these great Reward Points
it doesn't really match now if I was a
financial or investing influencer that
might make sense but if I'm a gardening
influencer just because they're the only
person who reached out and said hey
we'll give you 500 bucks to do the
sponsorship some money is not worth
taking but if we were to do that we
would definitely decrease our audience
and decrease the likelihood that they
want to tune into our stuff in the
future so the next thing I do is I was
associate with the wrong crowd the wrong
people people that their core values and
the things that they're interested in
directly conflict I'll give you a couple
examples for me one is like a snake oil
salesman so if somebody has a really
crappy product or they make these false
promises or false claims then me making
association with them would hurt my
brand and so the idea is if we wanted to
make sure we'd hurt your brand we'd make
sure to associate with the wrong people
next is I would need perfect conditions
don't start today start when you have
perfect conditions because the thing is
is that there are no perfect conditions
and so you're like well I will only
succeed if I have a really big set and
lots of people helping me and a script
and a teleprompter and all these special
effects if you need that to win you're
not going to win because what I can tell
you about every person that we talked
about earlier all of them started with
what they had and so if you really think
you're going to go all the way then be
willing to work with what you have and
the last one is I would never ever
change because even if things did start
working if we guaranteed that we didn't
change then we can guarantee that
eventually the conditions will change
and we will fail because you're like but
this thing started working I have to
keep doing that and then you slowly see
it stop working less and less and less
and less and you don't change with it
and at the same degree you change if
your brand never changes at all you have
changed and it means that there's
actually greater and greater distance
between who you are and who you
represent yourself to be and that long
term will sync you and so so if
everything I just covered if you do
these things you can guarantee that your
brand will not win and will not succeed
in the long term and so if we're being
enterprising about this what if we flip
it because that might just be the recipe
to succeeding in the long term which
means we talk about the stuff that we
know and that we're interested in we
stay consistent with it and we just
start and we keep going you wait way too
long to sell it all if you are going to
sell to begin with because you want to
make sure that you always provide so
much more value than you ever ask from
your audience and then if you do choose
to sell something you sell something
that actually requires you to change
nothing about who you are if I already
love this type of tank top and people
know that I've been wearing it for a few
years then it would make sense for me to
say by the way this is the brand I use
no one's going to be upset by that
because it makes sense based on
everything they've seen up to this point
and I would associate with people who
are like me who have audiences like mine
who care about the things like I do so
that those audiences combine and
compound unto each other rather than
duding all of the associations I spent
so much time curating and putting
together to say this is what I stand for
and we would wait for in perfect
conditions which often means today
because there are no perfect conditions
and finally being willing to embrace
change because change is the only
constant that will happen in braining at
all is that the platforms will change
the media will change the packaging will
change and you yourself will change over
this whole time and you have to be
willing to do that or eventually you
will die and so these are the steps if
reversed that can create a brand in my
opinion might be able to follow to get
rich in today influence Revolution